what's been the easiest year you've had
as a filmmaker and then what's been your
toughest year yeah I think my easiest
year was I was 2000 when I I booked my
first film riot the Showtime film I was
brought in under tragic tragic
circumstances the guy who wrote it was
um
Joseph Vasquez and he passed away and
they were looking for a new director and
it turns out most of the producers went
to USC and there was buzz about my my
thesis film called por Vida and I mean I
did my first movie right when I got out
of film school and then I got a
commercial agent then I was doing
commercials and my other film got into
Sundance it was such a year and yes
there is some happenstance in luck I
don't like to call it luck because
someone died but a writer director
passed away they needed someone to
direct his segment I had to come in and
change it because the way he wrote it
he's from New York he's a brilliant
writer director from New York New York
ed and had to make it more LA but that
was a I was thinking wow I just
how did this happen I'm directing a film
for Showtime and I just got out of film
school is this really happening and then
I was going to Berlin and go into all
these film festivals so but but the
point of ignition was me getting that
Showtime movie and then the worst year
was probably the year I did I don't even
like looking at the film because the
producers were not honest but cut out
eight core scenes and they said we're
gonna shoot these scenes in LA and I
said yeah let's shoot the scenes because
we don't shoot these eight scenes that
story won't make sense so we wrapped the
film we got to LA and they said we're
not shooting those scenes they never
planned to shoot the scenes and they did
shoot some additional new scenes and I
found out and I told them I said you
can't do this I'm DGA
and I will report this to the Union and
my DP said he would report it also to
his Union and they said well if you go
to the Union we'll just drag your name
through the mud I said go ahead and
nothing's gonna come up so I had to go
to my Union in and fight just to shoot
some of the new scenes and I almost
reached the point of surrender where I
said to myself I worked really hard to
get into USC and I worked really hard to
come up with the money to pay you from
my mess to get my master's degree why am
i doing this why am I gonna spend six
months of my life on a film only to have
it re-edit it and have stuff film behind
my back this is BS but what I did
instead is instead of I just refused to
stand under the banner called victim
like I'm gonna learn from this and now
I'm a fiercely independent filmmaker I
gotta have final cut and the films that
have done well for me my most
award-winning films are films where I
had to final say in the creative cut
because I know but I want them clear
about my vision but it was a bad year
because I wanted to claim the Alan
Smithee clause which is if you don't
like the film and if it deviates too
much from your vision you don't have to
have your name on it but if I took one
name off of it I would lose all the
residuals and I needed the money
so not only did the film not do well it
didn't bomb it just was very very
lukewarm and then I kind of got a little
blacklisted for running to the Union and
the people were I became a distant
outpost like no one wants to really
touch me her saying this guy went to the
DJ like a little baby and people didn't
really want to talk to me or hire me and
that was a very tough year for me but I
recovered and you know we survived we
survived and we overcome and we keep
going my aunt used to say onward ever
keep going there's a Japanese proverb
it's some fall down eight times get up
nine times I have that above my wall
above my desk in my office
you